hey it's evan welcome to my kitchen
today i'm gonna be making salsa now i'm
not great at making salsa i never make
salsa i'm not even a huge fan of salsa
but
somebody on my email list a loyal
follower uh robert wrote in and he said
i make some of the best salsa in the
world i packaged it up and i'd love for
you to try it so i thought you know
tonight i'm having a few people over
we're going to play some card games and
what better way than to treat them with
some salsa and i wanted to go through
his recipe
give it a try see how easy it is and uh
see what the results are now nina is
here making some homemade hamburgers too
she may see her in the background
walking back and forth don't get too
distracted you know focus on me not her
come on people uh so here we go let's
make some salsa
so here is the salsa here's the pack and
here's a letter from robert so robert
wrote in and say evan we finally got our
product in so as promised here's a
sample i like to add cilantro and
jalapeno to the veggies when i blend
them but that's something you can avoid
if you don't care for those flavors i
wanted to make a video showing how to
prepare the salsa i was going to set all
the items out on the table and show how
easy it was to prepare this is probably
a good idea right i think so robert i
figured i could then upload it to my
website afterwards as i contemplated
this i had a bright idea i thought hey
maybe evan could make a demo video for
me since he has such a good on-camera
presence and a better face than me too
just a thought enjoy
robert and he signed it so robert this
one especially for you i hope is good i
hope my friends enjoy your salsa tonight
we've got the ingredients for those you
guys watching here's the products let me
pull it up to the camera a little bit so
it's called red crow salsa makes four
pints salsa starter kit and the recipe
is on the back and it's easy and tasty
so let's see how it is made in the usa
so one thing i like about this recipe is
on the back and again i am not
great in the kitchen and uh
yeah so i'm not good at recipes and i
don't want anything difficult
so this is really good this is super
easy for someone like me so it says
blend the veggies in a food processor
step one onion green pepper peeled
cucumber add diced tomatoes crushed
tomatoes
mix it in the bowl with the red crow
spice packet with some cider vinegar
chill and then serve so pretty easy for
someone like me who doesn't know what
he's doing so let's give it a try i'm
not sure of exactly everything that i'm
gonna need you see my face hey guys
uh so i got a whole bunch of stuff
prepared and we'll see how it goes when
i get started so i've got my recipe i've
got my onion cucumber green pepper
the
crushed tomatoes diced tomatoes my knife
cutting board bowl for the waste full
for the salsa
my vitamix i don't have a food processor
so i got the vitamix all set up and
let's see how this thing works
one thing that i found a little hard
with this was the recipe it says for an
onion and a peeled cucumber so i have a
bit of a challenge because onions come
in lots of different sizes so i don't
use a large onion small onion what i'm
doing here so i picked
you know i guess kind of medium sized
onion here
and the cucumbers
thank you nina nina just gave me a
peeler but i'm a lazy person so i'm not
actually going to feel this
i need i need simple recipes okay super
simple uh so things that require extra
work i'm probably not gonna do i'm gonna
find a way around it so that's my style
oh so same thing with the cucumbers okay
you either get these little cucumbers
this is like an average i don't know
maybe uh three quarters of a foot long
here
and you've got the crazy long ones that
are in saran wrap so i don't know what
cucumber do i need so i'm going with a
smaller one so that would help it was
unwrapping on the package here what kind
of cucumber but anyway
let's cut this stuff up so the first
step here is to get the onion the green
pepper and the cucumber into the food
processor so i'm gonna cut those up and
put them into the vitamix and uh
see what happens i thought it'd be
better you can see my face
you can also see nina working away
making some homemade hamburgers which
will be way more delicious i'm sure
uh but
here we go let's see what i can do so
onion
please ignore my chopping skills because
i don't really know what i'm doing but
we'll cut that off
next up green pepper man those onions
are making me cry
so apparently if you have a candle
around
you it's supposed to help with the onion
i probably should have done that a lot
sooner
i set it up for nina
and thought i'm not really going to chop
that much
man this burns okay cucumber
i need to i need some
i feel better
uh cucumber now i'm not too worried
about cutting it up and i have no skills
in it anyway so it's all going in the
food processor anyway
so pop it into my vitamix
and that should be step number one done
i gotta pop it into
obviously the vitamix put on the power
and we'll see what happens okay
everything is in my vitamix ready to go
nina's got some hamburger buns and
mushrooms around here that she's using
so i'm not going to touch that let's see
what happens we put all this stuff in i
love the vitamix by the way because
it's uh great and mixing stuff up you
can crunch a cell phone in here if you
want but let's see how it works with
just these veggies
okay i think we're done we've got all of
our veggies mixed together
next step
nina actually just dropped an egg on the
floor and so she's cleaning that up
this is what happens when there's too
many people in the kitchen doing stuff
i'm in her way it's on my phone okay
the last step here
is i gotta mix
this stuff that i just mixed up together
with my uh tomatoes so blow that out
thank you candle my eyes feel a lot
better even though it's kind of an
embarrassing moment there on youtube
let's pull this out
pour it into my bowl
very nice
smells good very fresh hopefully that's
a good ratio
next
i have my
diced tomatoes and it's supposed to be
14 ounce can they didn't have a 14 ounce
can so i bought the bigger one so i'll
try to pour about half of this
looks about right
and then
a 28 ounce can of crushed tomatoes so
this is 28 pounds put the whole thing in
last step number three mix in bowl with
red pro spice packet and a quarter cup
of apple cider vinegar now i don't have
apple cider vinegar and i didn't want to
buy a whole thing of apple cider vinegar
just for this so we're going to
improvise and see what happens without
the apple cider vinegar
if it doesn't work out i'm going to
blame the apple cider vinegar and not my
skills
so we're going to open this up
i can tell you it smells good already
okay then mix it up so let me show you
what i got here
i got
oh i almost spilled on the floor
i got green goo
red goo
and the mix so we're gonna put it
together
see what happens
and here
is my finished product
i do not want to spill this there we go
look at that
looks like tomato sauce yeah
all right let's see how see how it
tastes
baby that's not bad actually that's
pretty good
it's kind of sweet
it's sweeter than i thought it would be
you want to try it try to try some of
this here
no no the ducks tomatoes are supposed to
go in just as it is
here try
nina's official taste test here we go
that's so good
okay
last step here is to uh
chill and serve so i said
i have a little bit more oh my god
it's good it's it's some it's got a
little kick to it it's sweet no there's
a taste it
doesn't taste like
okay that's it for my spoon so as i said
i got some friends coming over
and uh
i want to serve them
this i've got some
multi-grain
premium tortilla chips that we're gonna
serve after i chill this they're coming
in about
two hours so hope that's enough time for
this to chill
so i'm gonna pop this in the fridge
make some space
make some space
and i'll report back see what people
think
okay
i took the salsa out of my fridge and
i'm having my friends over so we've got
stephanie rosanna alex
christine and nina
and they're all super nervous to be on
youtube
but they're all gonna try the dip at the
same time and see what happens
see what happens
are you allowed to double dip that's a
little gross man i don't know you have
to ask the fellow people at your table
okay go for it
one two
or something no
but it's like sweet it has like three
minutes of avocado
it has flesh
but it's sweeter
i don't know
i think i like pepperoni and slices some
spices
yeah what's that
so what's in it
what's in it what's the secret let me
read the ingredients here
ingredients sugar and spice and
everything nice
sweet
all right we're going to enjoy our games
and our salsa thank you robert for a
single chip
thank you this is beautiful okay
everybody wave bye
bye bye
okay so it's almost midnight i've just
finished my party everybody left we had
a good time i still got a bit of a mess
here to clean up the good news is the
salsa was a big hit and uh it's kind of
addictive you eat wine and you gotta
have more and have more and i'm not a
huge salsa guy but uh this one is a good
mix it's got some sweetness to it that i
haven't tasted in other sauces and it's
also got a little bit of a kick but not
too much it was uh really interesting
now
it was it was a pretty good hit people
were addicted to it they uh they were
surprised to find out that it was by
just a local or entrepreneur startup
trying to get their message out
so thank you rob but it was great it
should come with a warning though
because this makes a ton of salsa so if
i show you here
this is the bowl i had we we've oh bring
this up a bit we made like a little bit
of a dent we maybe had half of what was
in here and we went through
two bowls
of
the major
tortillas so like you think of the
regular size packs hopefully it was
somewhere in the video before but like
240 grams of tortillas times two bags
times six people and we only had like
half of the salsa
i am super full i'm gonna have to do
like some squats or something here after
to kind of work that off but uh overall
it was great a fan of the product
everybody seemed to like it so congrats
robert on a great product for those of
you interested let me pull it up here
again so the company is called let me
bring this up
it's red crow salsa made in the usa
and the website
i think is on the back here is it can
you read that let's bring that in
www.redcrowsalsa.com
anyway i hope you guys enjoyed my quick
and terrible cooking demonstration and
the reviews of uh of the salsa if you
guys like this video you want to see
similar ones give it a thumbs up below
let me know what you liked about it
leave a comment and uh i'll see you guys
soon i got some cleaning up today